ladies and gentlemen miss Audrey Hepburn
and mr. Gregory Peck
without writers there would be no words
without words there would be no movies
and without movies there would not have
been sixty glorious years of Academy
history you're absolutely right your
royal highness
and I'd like to express for all actors
the admiration we feel for the men and
women who write the stories we tell on
the screen the roles we play and the
words we speak the nominees for the best
screenplay based on material from
another medium are Tony Huston for the
dead James James didn't a fatal
attraction
Danica Rick Michael her and Gustav
Hosford for Full Metal Jacket Mark
Peplow and Bernardo Bertolucci for The
Last Emperor
hellström Ryder Yongsan rasa brainstorm
and paired with Birdland for my life as
a dog
and the winner is the winners are mark
Peplow and
say great honor and hugely encouraging
to anyone else who wants to ride
impossible movies all month um I want to
thank Bernardo for taking me to China
and for giving me the chance to discover
a nother half of the world we live in
I want to thank Jeremy the producer and
I want to thank a great Italian director
who first showed me a film of Bernardo's
and first went to China to make a
document to his own and that is
Michelangelo Antonioni
and he has made us both believe in
movies years and say I love my daughter
lo um thank you
I I've been walking all around and I
didn't let me in then I show my statues
they let me in and just came on time
thank you thank you
the nominees for Best Screenplay written
directly from the screen
ah blue mouth for a while Avon farm
goodbye children
James L Brooks broadcast news John
Boorman / Hope and Glory
Patrick Shanley for moonstruck
Woody Allen for radio day
is John Patrick Shanley
oh uh Wow I don't care man I don't care
we're supposed to be cool this is
incredible
I'd like to thank everybody who ever
punched or kissed me in my life and
everybody who I have a punched or kissed
I'd like to thank Norman Jewison
especially because I would not be here
if it was not for that man I'd like to
thank the multimedia princess shower and
the remarkable Nick Cage and the
ensemble cast of moonstruck which was
great
I'd like to thank my agent Janine
Edmonds I'd like to thank my wife Jane
for the love that she gives me and I'd
like to thank Patrick Palmer for
producing the picture and Bonnie palace
for associate producing the picture I'm
sure I'd like to thank a lot of other
people but I'm going home and dying